Oh am I allowed to say that your
daughter's here she's like looking over
yes you let angel looking over my
shoulder how are we doing in the
interview comes out she's like so on
your Instagram you called Ryan blazing
hot you Vienna yeah how do you feel
about that well that's actually my
Christian name it's also been a my dance
under yeah that in yogurt balls
good dancing involves Tom is there a
song song yes I'm the Cisco of mm
speaking of your husband you cou
cucarachas the cutest pet name I've ever
heard me Kolkata
it means Roche medical in Spanish
because you're my husband in his movie
just won't die what's the best pet name
you've ever had um the kids in school
teach me with Salman
Salmonella strange stuff what would you
like to call penny oh he's so hot he's
frozen
I'm like dry edit hole this is Michael
Bryce have an executive protection agent
I've extracted my client cleanup is
required what I loved in this film is
that you called yourself not a bodyguard
but an executive protection
adrià la la yeah what would you call an
actor you had to sort of give it that
sort of unemployed hobo imaginative
vagabond yes exactly
an imaginative Baga I like that one I
love that Samuel Jackson is known for
the f-bomb yes and you put him to shame
in this movie ah about sign and I do it
in two languages did I get a little
renditions get demonic so can we go out
with an F bomb for Fandango here you go
get Man's bodyguard
see it in theaters August 18 I'll bet
your mother house
[Music]